All right, let's see,
we're on page 471.
We'll start with
section 6 now.
So let's do the first problem,
and I will do it in magenta.
Problem number one.
3 plus diamond over 2 is
equal to 7 and 1/2.
And they say, what number,
when used in the place of
diamond above, makes
the statement true?
Well, they're just making the
diamond a variable, right?
So we could just say 3 plus
x over 2-- [? instead ?]
of an x instead of the diamond,
because that's what
we're used to-- is equal to--
well, we could write this as a
decimal if we want, 7.5.
Multiply both sides by
2, so you get 3 plus
x is equal to 15.
x is equal to 12.
So that's choice D.
Or we could say diamond is equal
to x is equal to 12.
OK, problem number two.
They have this thing drawn.
Let me draw what they drew.
I'll do it in a different
color.
They have, like, a transversal
here, and then they have one
line that goes like this.
And then they have another
line that goes
something like this.
And then, let's see, they
wrote a bunch of stuff.
They wrote, this is angle 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and these
are lines l and lines m.
And they say in the figure
above, l is parallel to m.
All right, parallel lines.
If l is parallel to m, the sum
of the measures of angles 2
and 4 must equal the sum of the
measures of which of the
following pairs of angles?
So the sum of 2 and 4.
And actually, we know
another thing.
We know that 2 and 4 are equal
to each other, right?
Because they're opposite
angles.
But anyway, what angles would
be the same as 2 plus 4?
Well, we can just do what we
learned in geometry class
about corresponding angles.
We know that this angle is the
same thing as this angle.
And we actually know that that
angle is also the same thing
as this angle, because
they're opposite.
And that first one, we know that
they are because they're
corresponding.
That angle's the same
as this one.
So 2 plus 4 should be the
same thing as 6 plus 8.
And all we used is corresponding
angles to say,
well, 4 is going to
be the same as 8.
2 is the same as 6.
And we also know that 6 and
8 are the same, and 2
and 4 are the same.
So it's choice D.
Problem number three.
Let me draw this table, because
it looks like we'll
have to use it.
So I have a box here and then
we draw four lines.
All right, soon. almost there.
And then they say, Men,
Women, Total,
Employed, Unemployed, Total.
And they wrote in the numbers
27,000-- those are 0's--
48,000, 21,500, and 50,500.
In the table above, describing
the Preston City workforce--
the table is partially filled
in-- based on the information
in the table, how many women in
the Preston city workforce
are unemployed?
So we want to figure out women
that are unemployed.
We need to figure
out this box.
So how do we do that?
Well, first we can figure out
the women that are employed
because there's 48,000
workers.
27,000 are men.
So we just subtract 27,000 from
48,000, so there's going
to be 21,000 women.
And then if there's 21,000
women-- I just subtracted--
and-- no, sorry, there's 21,000
employed women, because
we're in the Employed column--
and there are
21,500 total women.
Well, then we just
subtract again.
21,500 minus 21,000.
There must be 500 unemployed
women in Preston City, and
that's choice A.
OK, problem number four.
And I will switch from
this kind of
nauseating color, I think.
A group of students washed
cars to raise money.
The net amount, A, in dollars
raised by washing k cars, is
given by the function-- oh,
well, they tell us, A of k.
So this is how much you've made
after washing k cars, is
4k minus 30.
If the group washed 15
cars, what is the
net amount they raised?
Well, this seems unbelievably
easy, because they tell you
that k is 15, so A of 15 is
equal to 4 times 15, minus 30.
4 times 15 is 60, minus 30.
That just equals 30.
They raised $30.
That's choice E.
If I was taking the SAT, I would
have paused, just to
make sure I didn't
miss something.
I'm actually pausing
now to make sure I
didn't miss a trick.
But I think that's it.
That's kind of one of those
freebie quick questions.
OK, problem number five.
And I'll switch colors
for variety.
If xr is equal to v, and v is
equal to kr, and we also know
that rv does not equal 0,
which also tells us that
neither you of these numbers
can equal 0, which of the
following is equal to k?
And all of the choices have
just x's and some numbers.
So we want to write
k in terms of x.
So xr is equal to v, and
v is equal to kr.
So we know that xr is equal to
kr, and since we know that r
does not equal 0, we can divide
both sides of this
equation by r and
they cancel out.
And we get x is equal to
k, or k is equal to x.
So that is choice D.
Well, they're giving us a lot
of quick problems, but I
that's good.
I can fit a lot into
one video.
OK, problem number six.
The eggs in a certain basket
are either white or brown.
If the ratio of white eggs to
brown eggs-- I should probably
do it in those colors, but I'm
not to confuse you-- the ratio
of white to brown is
equal to 2 over 3.
Each of the following could be
the number of eggs in the
basket, except-- so this
is a tricky one.
So the ratio of white to
brown is 2:3, right?
White to brown is equal
to 2 over 3.
Or another way we could say it
is, white is equal to 2/3
times the brown eggs.
And so the total eggs in the
basket are going to be white
plus brown.
And so we could write, this w,
it as 2/3 of the number of
brown eggs is the white eggs--
that's what we figured out
here-- plus the brown eggs.
So the total number of baskets
is-- let's see, what's 2/3
plus-- 1 is the same thing
is 3/3, right?
The total number of baskets
is 5/3 times the
number of brown eggs.
We know we can't have a
fractional number of eggs, so
we know that this has to
be a whole number.
If we said 5/3B, this is the
first choice is equal to 10,
could that be a choice?
Let's see, B would have to be
3/5 times 10, which would be--
this cancels out-- that
works, right?
Because then B would be
6, so that could work.
Well, I think we already
know, right?
The total number of baskets
has to be divisible by 5.
Because B is equal to the total
number times 3 over 5.
I just used this equation, 5/3B
is equal to the total.
Multiply both sides
[? by the ?]
reciprocal, you get this.
And the only choice that's not
divisible by 5 is choice B.
Hope I didn't rush it, but I had
to finish under the wire.
I'll see